allez paris direct se poursuit tout de
suite avec notre grand format du jour
qui nous conduit cette fois en argentine
un pays pionnier en matière de droits
des personnes trans depuis 10 ans dans
ce pays pourtant conservateurs sur
beaucoup de sujets sociétaux reconnaît
le droit à chacun à l'identité de genre
propre en dehors de toutes
considérations biologiques mais vous
allez voir dans ce document que les
discriminations restent très fortes
malgré la loi eléonore vanel et nicolas
champ
dans le miroir le reflet d'une enfant
bien dans sa peau
juanita à 7 ans dans sa chambre des
patins des fleurs une maison de poupée a
signé garçon à la naissance elle s'est
pourtant toujours sentie comme une fille
prêt
et tu les utilisent
au début déboussolé sa mère marianne a
suivi les conseils d'une psychologue
pour soutenir sa fille dans sa
transition de genre et montre on a
fabriqué une poupée avec un pénis parce
qu'on n'en trouve pas en argentine ça
n'existe pas on l'a fait sur les
conseils de la cie colloque pour qu'elle
puisse jouer avec avec d'autres enfants
nous sommes à 300 km de la capitale
buenos aires azul ville conservatrice de
70000 habitants faire accepter la
transidentité de juanita n'a pas été
évident le mans valérie et passionné il
ya eu plusieurs situations par exemple
dans un hôpital où on l'a appelé par son
nom de garçons et elle répondait je ne
m'appelle pas comme ça
fait énormément
pour entamer des démarches la famille de
la petite fille entre en contact avec un
avocat des droits de l'homme
facundo achats gars prend en charge le
dossier en 2020 juanita est alors âgé de
cinq ans sur draper j'ai essayé de la
connaître un peu savoir si elle se
percevait comme une fille mais sans me
montrer trop intrusif non plus donc je
lui demandais de se dessiner et elle
s'est représentée avec les cheveux longs
et une robe rires et quand l'avocat lui
demande de décrire son prénom la petite
fille a inscrit celui qu'elle s'est elle
même choisi juanita la procédure pour
changer ses papiers d'identité prend
moins d'un mois
en argentine depuis 2012 la loi
d'identité de genre permet de choisir
son genre et de changer d'état civil sur
simple demande et sans aucune limite
d'âge le pays a été le premier roman
d'instaurer une telle mesure encore
aujourd'hui parmi les plus avancés à
l'international
il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir l'avis
d'un psychologue ou d'un psychiatre
car avec cette loi est transgenre n'est
plus considérée comme une pathologie
ce n'est pas perçue comme une maladie
mentale et aucune opération ou
traitement médical n'est exigée
depuis l'adoption de ce texte il ya dix
ans plus de 9000 personnes ont
officiellement demandé le changement de
leur identité de genre
marcela romero a été l'une des co trice
de cette loi avant gardiste dix ans plus
tard elles manifestent pour demander au
législateur d'aller encore plus loin
[Musique]
une loi globale qui doit être débattu au
congrès avec pour objectif de garantir
davantage d'inclusion sociale car dans
ce pays pionnier en matière des droits
des trans 80% d'entre eux vivent
pourtant dans la précarité
[Musique]
on a l'espérance de vie d'une femme
trans en argentine et de 35-40 ans à
cause de l'exclusion sociale et en
dehors du système entraîne un manque de
soins médicaux un manque de
considération pour trouver un logement
du travail de tous ceux dont bénéficient
les autres personnes
une forte discrimination qui se traduit
parfois par des crimes de haine en 2020
129 personnes trans en ont été victimes
à 32 ans fiorella a été confronté
quasiment toute sa vie à cette violence
très ancrée dans la société
j'ai vécu à la rue j'ai dû me prostituer
je n'ai pas pu terminer mes études
secondaires pas pu trouver du travail
donc sur le plan personnel ça m'a
énormément affecté
et l'histoire de fiorella est loin
d'être un cas à part en argentine moins
d'un quart des personnes trans terminent
leurs études secondaires
95 % ont un emploi précaire ou sont au
chômage une grande majorité tire ses
revenus de la prostitution
conscient de ces difficultés d'accès à
l'emploi ce grand groupe financier a
créé en 2018 un réseau d'entreprise
baptisé pride connexion celui-ci promeut
des mesures plus inclusive envers les
lgbt plus pour mieux les intégrer au
monde du travail
par exemple dans un entretien d'embauché
on est amené à utiliser des pronoms il
ou elle donc on va ouvertement demandé
aux candidats qu'elle prône ont souhaité
vous qu'on utilise des choses comme ça
qui ne nous semblait pas si évidente par
le passé sebastian fait partie des deux
salariées trans de l'entreprise deep et
morgane embauché fin 2020 ce cadre de 36
ans supervise une vingtaine de personnes
avec son exemple il espère faire évoluer
les mentalités elle l'associé dans notre
société on ne s'imagine pas qu'une
personne trans puissent travailler dans
ce genre de lieu donc le simple fait
d'être ici d'occuper un poste de
direction dans une entreprise
multinationale
c'est un acte révolutionnaire d'une
certaine façon
pour que la situation de sebastian ne
soit plus l'exception le gouvernement a
instauré en 2021 un quota de 1 % de
personnes transgenres dans le service
public le texte de loi encourage
également les embauches dans le secteur
privé via des déductions d'impôts une
manière pour l'argentine de se
distinguer une fois encore comme
pionnière des droits des trans
on poursuit maintenant avec les sports
et les adieux au tennis d'un grand
champion français malheureusement
éliminée dès le premier tour de roland
garros j'ai nommé jo wilfried tsonga
regardez